僕の動画によく出る人でまあ僕
正樹拓海っていう3人がいるんですけども僕は結構な外出ると結構ありがたい事にお声
をかけていただけます本当にありがとうございます
タブンネ身長大きいのもあると思うしめっちゃで構成だからすごい目立つっていうのは
あると思うんですけど
正木も顔が特徴的なのと正木も実は慎重た
ないんですけどもみあげも長いせいかをも特徴的なので番先も結構話しかけられる
みたいですでも彼はどうでしょう
匠服シャツ
[音楽]
エイダじゃないかもしれないイヤホン度悪い意味ではないんです心臓まで正ヒット僕に
比べると小さいし
馬崎と顧客とインパクトあるんですけどもからまあ
入って個人的に凄い1回東京にライドに検証してみたいことがあったんですけどもう
やっぱ原作って若い人が多いじゃないですかと話し国金をポツンっておいておくと
バレるかバレないのかという検証をしてみたいと思いまして
実際にやってきました vdr どうぞありがとうございました
追求はでございます長がリーモノっ
ないですね
1作品としてはまあ13くらい入って生まれたか力を丸め
翔平となりますぜんざいできないのこんな感じになって
ちなみにこっちでも厳しい日出せるんで何かしてくださいと言ったらしてくれます
例えば
屈伸て打ちましたずっとそれは
かぶってくれまってますくっつけてるんですけども徐々にコーポラスいく話すよつば
だけますけど寄せ見てみましょう
なんか税経とか多いのにねぇ
ついてきたねー
石田してみようかめっちゃかで500万ニーズを投与ベテルチャンネルで出てるわけ
ですからそれなりに知名度はあるはずなんですけどもう米でも待って
保っている1月から言って全然違うした跡あっ
[音楽]
って待ってますっ監視カメラにちょっと言われだある意味これで俺がわかるところと
思うん
あってか早急写真撮ってって言われた人ということはこれはノーカンだな
周りが use がたけどそろそろしか者9人でけどじゃあよ
いつも絡まれてるよ題材製品名無しなるなよねー
に食べられないと思います
はっはっは
あぶねーあぶねー入ってる気でちょっと今からはれたんですけども
さっき僕じゃあガーはれって絡まれた登録さあ連れがつけない
水場だったんでなれ農家感じましたねー
えっこれがこれが8型済み助けて
すごいん
たいというわけでマック
無理でしたこれじゃああるカフェばレター
パッケージ人たちや
セグくどいほっといわかってるんだ
なぜ dove するんですかなぁ
かかとなど内容を教えてください
[音楽]
win みんなには内緒だった
んでしょ分かったとか譚セ号咲きましたん
[音楽]
ターンた探せ
遠いてくださいこと言ってられると本物の柿が降ってバックハグしてるんで
察するといいん
水やすいとは思います
あが住んで一つに据えるよです
ああああああ
[音楽]
すごいなぁ
をぴょんぴょん桜庵たんです t パーク量多そうだよねー
に振って自分本当に返すけど言う
でもー
てんぞ
[音楽]
大ジャンプに付けたですシャー芯撮影かいいだろう
ソースの香りだなぁばいいのならばいいんん
[音楽]
me
ni
あっはぁ
はいというわけで結果から言うとバレエますね割れました張りました全然ばれた生腹
自分て使えば若い人が多いって
活気のある松田なって思いましたまた次の動画でお会いしましょうじゃあな